[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم
هذه العربيه
سفن حربيه روسيه تحمل صواريخ كاليبر تظهر
في البحر الاسود
والغربها وسرا ينقسم على نفسه
بعد فرنسا البرازيل ثاني المتاهلين الى
الدور الثاني في كاس العالم بعد فوز صعب
على سويسرا
اجتماع تركيا
على سوريا ينتهي دون قرار واردوغان يكرره
تهديد
ايضا
في ازمات تويتر معركه مع ابل ويؤكد ان
الشركه هددت بحجم التطبيق من مجالها
[موسيقى]
30% من مطوري التطبيقات عبر متجررها اذا
اخر التفاصيل المتعلقه بهذه الاتهامات
التي يقيلها ماسك لشركه ابل بعد ان هدد
كما قلت قبل قليل بحجم تطبيق تويتر
صحيح اذا السلسله جديده من الضربات
الروسيه تتوقعها اوكرا لهذا الاسبوع مع
رصد سفينه روسيه تحمل صواريخها في البحر
الاسود
صواريخ من نوع كاليبر ما يشير الى موجه
جديده من الهجوم الروسي
تقرا
سفن حربيه اخرى
في ظروف صعبه ويضيف ان خطوات اضافيه
اوكرانيا
الدول الغربيه منذ اسابيع وهو وضع السقف
لسعر النفط الروسي من اجل حرمان الكرملين
من مصدر لتمويل الحرب لكن الامر ليس بهذه
البساطه خاصه مع الخبر العاجل الذي سمعناه
قبل قليل حيث الاتحاد الاوروبي
اسعار النفط الروسي وهو موضوع صان يناقشه
مع ضيفنا اليوم لنعرف اسبابه وتداعياته
على اسواق همم
[موسيقى]
ازمه الطاقه العالميه وارتفاع الاسعار في
الولايات المتحده يدفعني واشنطن للبحث عن
طرق تثبيت السعر محليا صحيفه بوليتيكو
الامريكيه افادت بان الولايات المتحده
تضغط على الاتحاد
الاوروبي وايضا ينطبق على المستوى
الداخليه
يتراوح بين 66 و70$ المقترح هذا اوبل
بمعارضه كل من بولندا دول البلطيق اليونان
مالطا وقبرص التي تفضل رفع سقف السعر او
التوصل لالي التعويض لهذه الدول التي
تعتمد على حركه الناقله النفطيه قبل ذلك
كان وزراء ماليه مجموعه السبع اعلنوا
عزمهم عن فرض سقفا لسعر النفط الروسي عبر
انشاء تحالف دولي يحضر تقديم اي خدمات
للنقل البحريه في حال بيع النفط بسعر اعلى
من الحد المتفق عليه من قبل هذا التحالف
ومن المتوقع ان يدخل هذا القرار حيز
التنفيذ في الخامس من ديسمبر المقبل
[موسيقى]
محاولات واشنطن خفض اسعار الوقود على
المواطنين الامريكيين دفع الاداره للنظر
جنوبا نحو دوله ربما غير متوقعه فنزويلا
بسبب العلاقات
على كاهل الرئيس
الاذن لشركه النفط العملاقه لانتاج وتصدير
النفط من فنزويلا بعد قرار كراكس نافع
المحادثات مع جماعه المعارضه في العاصمه
المكسيكيه ولتيكو نقلت عن مسؤول في
الاداره قوله ان تخفيف العقوبات غير مرتبط
سوق النفط وارجعه فقط
السير على طريق السعاده الديمقراطيه في
البلاد حسب قول المسؤول الامريكي القرار
الامريكي ياتي ايضا قبل الموعد النهائي
تشديد العقوبات على روسيا في الخامس من
ديسمبر والتي يمكن ان يعكر صفوه اسواق
النفط العالميه بموجب الترخيص الصادر عن
الخزانه الامريكيه يحضر على شركه النفط
الفنزويليه الحكوميه تلقي ارباح من مبيعات
النفط الناتجه عن مشروعها المشترك مع شركه
شيفرون لكن رغم التصريح الامريكي من غير
المحتمل الي يصل المزيد من النفط الفنزلي
الى الاسواق قريبا قبل ضخ النفط في
فنزويلا يتعين على شركه شارون اصلاح
المعدات المعطله واعاده توظيف مئات العمال
مع تزايد الهجره من فنزويلا اضافه لمواجهه
الانقطاعات في الكهرباء وتهديدات الامنيه
بما في ذلك سرقه البنزين ايضا ستواجه
شابرون مشكلات فنيه جمع في حقول النفط
المتقدمه في فنزويلا وشبكه معقده من
العقوبات الامريكيه المتبقيه التي يجب
تغييرها لضمان اصول المزيد من النفط
الفنزلي بالاسواق عالميه يصبح هناك مشكله
كبيره في الحقول عندما لا يتم الانتاج
بشكل دائم كما تعلمون بوليتيكول التقت
بخبراء في القطاع النفطيه من فنزويلا
واتفقوا على ان حجم الاموال اللازمه
للاستثمار في البلاد لاستعاده الانتاج
المفقود قد يصل الى 50 مليار دولار رقم
مهول كما ان شركه شيفرون قد تتمكن من
اضافه ما يصل الى 30,000 برميل نفط يوميا
الى الانتاج خلال الاشهر السته المقبله
وهو رقم اقل من ان يحدث اي فرق في السوق
العالميه بولتيكو واضافت انه على الرغم من
ان فنزويلا تمتلك اكبر احتياط نفطيه في
العالم الا ان الامر قد يستغرق شركه
كابرون عاما على الاقل لبدء اعاده الانتاج
انتاج النفط الى 200,000 برميل يوميا في
مشاريعها المشتركه مع شركه النفط الفنزليه
الحكوميه اخيرا انتاج فنزويلا من النفط
توقف عند حوالي سبع مئه الف برميل يوميا
هذا العام انخفاضا من اكثر من ثلاثه
ملايين يوميا في تسعينيات القرن الماضيه
[موسيقى]
راح حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من اوليون
الفرنسيه الدكتور حسان القبلي الباحث في
الاقتصاد السياسي اهلا بك دكتور حسان يعني
الاتحاد الاوروبي فاشله مجددا بالتوصل
للفاق لحد لو وضع حد لسقف
الاسعار اسعار النفط الروسي فعليا بظل
ضغوط امريكيه واضحه على دول بحسابات الربح
والخساره في حال همم تم التوصل الى هذا
القرار هل سيتاثر الروس هل ستتاثر عائدات
النفط الروسيه وكيف تاثير ذلك على الاسواق
العالميه
نعم بعد تحيه سيدتي الكريم منا اعتقد
اليوم ان الضغوطات الامريكيه تمارس منذ
فتره بالفعل من اجل وضع سقف الايثار النفط
الروسي الاوروبي
ان اي دوله سوف تحدد سعر
لن يباع اليها النفط الروسي نعتقد ان
اليوم هي يعني معركه كسر عظام صح التعبير
ولكن التخوف
هو على الصدمه كيف سيكون وقع على الاسباب
ونحن على بعد اسبوع ممكن على اجتماع
مجموعه اوبك
يعرف الجميع يعني قراراتها تاخذ بعين
الاعتبار بمصلحه الدول
العالم
السوق العالميه صدمه مثل هذه يعني لا يعرف
القران
الاسعار ولكن ما هو مؤكد على الاقل ان
الروس سوف يوقفون الضخ او البيع الى اي
طرف سوف يستعمل الاليه وربما الكميه التي
كانت تواجه الى اوروبا حتى البرغم من
العقوبات ونحن نتواصل مع العديد من
الخبراء النفطيين ان همم
ويباع في الاسواق العالميه كيف ستكون
الصدمه القرار الروسي نعتقد ان الجميع
اليوم يعرف ان الروس فيقطع ولكن دائما
اعود الى النظريه الاقتصاديه وهي دائما
يعني همم مفعله
السابق سيدتي الكريمه
كل مكان
نقص المعروف ترتفع الاسعار هنا سوف نلغي
الكميه المرجه والكل يعرف ان روسيا ثاني
دوله يعني في العالم عندما نلغي الروسي
الذي سوف يصل الى اوروبا كيف سوف تنتهي
بالاسعار لا اعتقد ان الاوروبيين ليوم
يحسبون ان ذهبوا
الى الناحيه الاخرى لفنزويلا كما جاء في
تقريركم عن فنزويلا التي عانت من عقوبه
طويلا منشات النفسيه تحتاج مده كبيره لانه
عندما يعرف الانتاج ودائما عن طريق خبراء
ونتحاورما دائما وتبادل مع بعض المعلومات
عندما يتوقف الانتاج في حقول النفط يكون
من الصعب في ما بعد تشغيل هذا العوده
بالقدره الانتاجيه التي
كانت عليها فيما
بكل تاكيد المشهد بعد الخامس من دي المشهد
النفطي العالمي اا يعني سيكون همم غير كل
ما قبله همم وبالتالي ما البدائل التي
امام الدول الاوروبيه على الاقل في هذا
الموضوع اذا ما لجات امريكا الى فنزويلا
وعوضت بعضا من
الخسائر كيف لنا ان نتخيل الخيارات
الاوروبيه هنا
في هذه الشخصيه
اللي سوف يذهب الى السوق الامريكيه قبل
السوق الاوروبيه لان هناك غضب في الشارع
الامريكي
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه اليوم ان
كانت ترفع العقوبات عن فنزويلا غضب شارع
امريكي يعني في الشارع الامريكي المشترك
الامريكي ولكن ماذا عن اوروبا يعرف الجميع
ان اليوم اوروبا وحتى همم في العالم وصلوا
الى الى يعني قدراتهم همم قدراتهم عند
الشيعه القصوى وحتى القرارات بالنسبه همم
كان قرار واضح جدا
بالنسبه
لهم ممكن حتى تضعف تخفيضات ولكن لروسيا هو
الشريك الرئيسي في اوروبا
فسيكون موقفها وحتى ان كان ممكن اقول جيدا
ان في حسابات الغرب حسابات اوروبيه ما
يحدث الان في الصين وسياسه صفر كوبي وممكن
لديهم توقعات بان ممكن روسيا لن تتمكن من
بيع منتجات اكثر الى الصين يعني تصدير
اكثر كميات الى الصين ولكن اعتقد
الروسيه يبقى دائما مطلوب لي وجهه اخرى
غير اوروبا باثر اخرى ممكن بالعقود
الطويله المدى سوف تكون همم اسعار تنافس
هي اكثر وللمعلومه وانا اتحدث اليوم
لديهم يعني هامش بين 10 و20 دولار يكون
تفاضلي الطويله المداء وهنا وهنا حتى يعني
ممكن على كميه الروسيه التي كانت تحظى بها
اوروبا
الهند دائما تطلب اسباب اخرى تطلب في ظله
العقوبات ولكن السؤال المطروح هو باي اليه
سوف يضعون هذا السبت في ايطار قانوني سوف
يفرضون على الروس بيبيع النفطم
[موسيقى]
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور حسن القطبي الواحد في
الاقتصاد السياسي من اول يوم عرفه اليك
اما عسكريا فتدرس وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
اقتراحا من شركه بونج لتزويد اوكرانيا
بقنابل دقيقه صغيره ورخيصه هذه القناه بل
تقول بوينج انها ستسمح لكاف بتوجيه ضربات
خلف الخطوط الروسيه
[موسيقى]
منذ ان دقه روسيا ابواب الحرب في اوكرانيا
تدفق كم نهائي من شحنه الاسلحه الغربيه
على مدى تسعه اشهر من الحرب ترسانه رغم
ضخمتها فان الغرب متعطش لارسال المزيد
منها وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه اعلنت مؤخرا
انها تدرس اقتراح من شركه بوينج لتزويد
اوكرانيا بقنابل دقيقه صغيره ورخيصه يتم
تثبيتها على صواريخ متوفره اسلحه متقدمه
تسمح لك بتوجيه ضربات خلف الخطوط الروسيه
يطلق عليها اسم قنبله ذات قطر صغير تطلق
من الارض هي واحده من نحو الست خطط لانتاج
ذخيره جديده لاوكرانيا وحلفاء واشنطن في
اوروبا
لتوفير صواريخ يصل مداها 2007 297 كلم فان
مدى القنابل محل البحث يبلغ 150 كم ما
يتيح الاوكرانيا ضرب اهداف عسكريه حيويه
صعبه ومواصلتها هجماتها المضاد لكنها
تحتاج لعمليه دقيقه تبدا بحساب المسافات
المراد استهدافها انطلاقا من الحدود
الروسيه
لكنه يعاني من معظمه خطيره اصطدمت بها
واشنطن كذلك وهي حقيقه ان اسلحه الغرب
تتلف سريعا باوكرانيا حسبما اكد مسؤولون
امريكيون واوكرانيون لموقع الاسبوع
[موسيقى]
ونذكر الخبر العاجل الذي اردده قبل قليل
عن صحيفه
بين اسرائيل وامريكا هذا الاسبوع
ايرانيه بعد فرنسا اصبحت البرازيل ثاني
المتاهلين الى الدور الثاني في كاس العالم
في قطر
السويسري في اطار منافسات المجموعه
السابعه
المونديال كانت احدى هذه المباراه الافضل
بين الكاميرون والصربيا وانتهت بالتعادل
بثلاثه اهداف لكل فريق اما المجموعه
الثامنه فكان فيها مباراه رائعه اخرى بين
جانا وكوريا الجنوبيه وانتهت لصالح غانا
بثلاثه اهداف لهدفئه
مباراه حاسمه في هذه المجموعه بين
البرتغال والاوروجواي
الى الدوحه ومفرد العربيه ليس بازاري يعني
ليث انت
تتواجد في الدوحه وتعيش هذه الاجواء
الموندياليه الجميله العلم كله يرقص
السامبا اليوم
ببعض الصدفه التقينا قبل قليل مشجع سعودي
مشجع مكسيكي موجودين هون رايحين يشجعوا
المنتخب او يحتفلوا مع المنتخب البرازيلي
بدي اسال الاستاذ
شو رايك في المباراه التي تحصل التي تحصل
بين المنتخب السعودي والمكسيك يوم
الاربعاء
منتخب عدو المكسيك اليوم لا خارج الملعب
احنا اخوان اما في الميدان باذن الله
المنتخب راح يفرض كلمته وزي ما انتصر على
الارجنتين في الفوز على المكسيك باذن الله
هذه اجواء المهر هل همم المونديال عفوا
راويه وهمم طاهر طاهر عفوا تعبان شويه على
كل حال الجميع سوف يتجه الان الى السوق
واقف حتى يحتفل مع البرازيليين الذي طبعا
كل ليله في السوق واقف تقام هذه
الاحتفالات واحنا هلا بدات الاحتفالات هون
ايه سعودي سعودي احنا في منطقه
ثانيه اذا بتشوف تفضل
على فكره شو بدي اقول لك شغله يعني انا
حضرت مباراه السعوديه تمام انا متاكد من
مره هاي السعوديه والمكسيك راح تكون عباره
عن حرب حرب بكره السعوديه
بتلاقوا المشجعين من جميع المنتخبات لتكون
صريحين يعني شفت الارجنتينيين مع مع
اكوادوريين همم شفت همم
ماشيين مع كوريين هذا الحلو برده
المونديال لازم نحكي انه برده هو فرصه
للتعرف على الاخر مش بس المنافسات
الرياضيه يعني شفنا برده في كان في
فعاليات ثقافيه شفنا حفلات موسيقيه من
بلدان عده تقام امام امام الملاعب كل مره
فهذا شيء جميل واذا حكينا مثلا مع الشباب
كان في واحد انت حكيت قبل شوي
بتمنى من الشعب الاردني كاس العالم 2026
انها تشد حيلها وطابته تجيبها اللاعبين
والناس وتدربهم اللي نجيب كاس العالم لنا
بمناسبه انه عندنا لاعبين يعني اقوياء
ومحترفين ولكن نحن بحاجه فقط الى العزيمه
بس انت طالع محل الرياضي بس انت هتطلع
عالم اسبانيا يلا اسبانيا
هي عنجد حميميه شوفنا كثير برده اكثر شفت
انه بالسوق واقف في مكان يتم فيه تعليم
الطبخ بين المشجعين كل واحد بيجيب وصفات
من بلده بعلمها للمشجع الاخر فهذا جميل ان
يكون ذلك في بلد عربي هنا في قطر وطبعا
يعني راح نحتفل بعد شويه ان شاء الله اذا
ما تعبنا من بنكون اللي بتكون حفلات
السامبا مثل ما حكت راويه قبل شويه دائما
كبيره وان شاء الله تكون الوضع تمام همم
المنتخب السعودي كيف احتفل ما شفنا منتخب
المغرب امس كيف احتل كيف احتفل بالاتصال
فرصه انت ايضا تعلمنا على كثير امور
متعلقه بالثقافه وبالمطبخ وغيره الفلسطيني
تحديدا لايت بازاري مفرد العربيه الى
الدوحه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
وتحياتنا اليك
النازحون السوريون شمال البلاد قلقون من
العمليه العسكريه واردوغان يؤكد ان بلاده
لن تنتظر اذنا من احد
[موسيقى]
لا تتنازل ولا ترضى بشيء عادي لكن المراعي
اجود زبادي مع زبادي المراعي كالاكل الف
كل ما
تسمع
قد لا يكون حقيقه
يجب التسليم بها
فمهما بلغت اهميه الخبر
تاكيده او نفيوه يعتمد فقط على المصدر
كواليس وسائل الاعلام العربيه والعالميه
في التفاعل مع الاخبار على كل المنصه
سنحاول ربط خيوط القصه ونطارد الخبر حتى
المصدر من المصدر الجمعه السابعه والنصف
على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
جرس الاغلاق
في هذه الاوقات على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
المشوار
ومع هذا لسه تعرف كيف تختار حليب المراعي
الطازج الفرق بين الامهات
[موسيقى]
الجيش سيواصلوا عمليته ضد من اسمائهم
بالتنظيمات الارهابيه حتى القضاء على
اخرهم
لحمايه حدودها على حد تعبيره
قبل ذلك رفضت قوات سوريا ديمقراطيه قصد
مقترحا روسيا يقضي بتسليم المناطق
الحدوديه لنظام السوري والانسحاب لمسافه
30 كم عن الحدود مع تركيا وافاد التقرير
اعلاميه ان الرفض جاء خلال اجتماع عقد بين
مسؤولين في قصد والقوات الروسيه في مطار
القامشلي واكدت التقارير ان التسليم قصد
للمنطقه الحدوديه الى قوات النظام من شانه
ان يوقف العمليه العسكريه البريه التي
تريد تركيا
على مناطق الفصائل الكرديه في شمال سوريا
منذ اكثر من اسبوع عبر مدافع الهاوزر
والطائرات الحربيه ولا تزال تركيا تؤكد
انها ستنفذ عمليه التوهل البري اليوم يقول
مسؤول تركي ان الجيش لا يحتاج الا لايام
قليله ليكون جاهزه للعمليه الكبرى وسيكون
في انتظار القرار السياسي مسؤولون اتراك
قالوا ان قوات المعارضه السوريه التي
تتحالف مع انقره اصبحت مستعده ايضا لنفس
المعركه في انتظار الاوامر يصف المسؤولون
الاتراك العمليه البريه بانها حتميه وذلك
لربط المناطق التي دخلت تحت سيطره تركيا
والمعارضه التابعه لها خلال عمليات
2016 يبرين الى ان تركيا ستتجه لاستهداف
مناطق منبج وعين العرب وترفعت في عملياتها
المرتقبه
امريكا كانت ابلغت تركيا بان لديها مخاوف
بالغه من ان يؤدي التصعيد العسكري الى
التاثير على مواجهه تنظيم داعش ايضا كانت
حذرت روسيا من شان عمليه تركيه من شانها
ان تزعزع الاستقرار ذلك رغم وصفها لمخاوف
تركيا بالمشروعه اما انقر فتقول انها
تتمسك بما تصفه بحقها في حمايه نفسها
وانها تبقي على خطوط الاتصال مفتوحه
سياسيا جيدا من اجل مواجهه عقبات اي قرار
فهي تواصل ماده حبال الود مع نظام السوري
منذ فتره الرئيس التركي اكد مجددا ان
الامور قد تعود الى نصابها مع سوريا وجدد
ما يقوله منذ اسابيع انه قد يلتقي الاسد
فلا خصومه دائمه في السياسه
[موسيقى]
بدات هذه الازمه بعد تفجير اسطنبول الذي
اسفر عن سقوط قتلى وجرحى قبل اسبوعين
وتهمت انقره واحداث حمايه الشعب الكرديه
في الهجوم رغم نفي الاخيره اليوم نشر
الامن التركي صوره احد عناصر حمايه وحدات
حمايه الشعب وقال انه احد المتورطين في
تفجير اسطنبول ويتم البحث عنه يضيف الامن
التركي ان عمليه التخطيط تمت في مدينه عين
العرب شمال سوريا وهي احدى المدن
المستهدفه في العمليه التي تريد تركيا ومع
تاكيد تركيا على ضروره العمليه العسكريه
يرى الناجحون السوريون شمال البلاد ان
حياتهم اصبحت اشبه بالمستحيله
وين الروح لا تركيا تستقبلنا لا دول برا
بتستخدمنا
وضرب هذا ما يعني تفائل نسوان عيال ارواح
يعني ما تقدر العيله بالليل بالنهار
نازحين صار لنا عشر سنين نازحين عم نتحول
من منطقه المنطقه
حدود تركيا
من اسطنبول محلل سياسي اهلا بك كيف يمكن
ان نفهم القرار التركي بتاجيل العمليه
تحيه لكم وللمشاهدين الكرام
الحكومه التركيه مصممه في العمليه
العسكريه والعمليه حتميه لكنه نعرف ان
هناك مفاوضات بين تركيا وامريكا وبين
تركيا وروسيا خاصه بين تركيا وروسيا هذه
هي المهمه يعني اهتمام تركي على ضوء
الاخضر الروسي المشكله الاساسيه اا حكومه
طهران
قلقان من فتح المجال للقوات التركيه في
الشماليه سوريا من قبل الروس ولهذا السبب
نعم الضغط على قوات خاصه
همم الرغبه من الحكومه الدمشق هذا موجود
يعني هناك اتفاق تركي روسي حول الضغط على
قوات خاصه لكنه فتح المجال الواسع لعمليه
شامله واسع لان الحكومه التركيه تريد ان
تدخل القوات بشكل واسع في شماليه سوريا
كما تل رفعت ومنبج معين العرب لكنه حكومه
طهران لا يريد ان فتح مجال يعني هل
العمليه سوف تكون واسعه او محدوده هذا
الذي هناك مفاضلات بين الجانبين وله سبب
اخر خبر
سياسيه للتواصل الى حل بين الاطراف يعني
الا ترى اي فرصه للحل ترضي الجميع كان
هناك ايضا حديث باحدى الصحف التركيه عن
موقف امريكي ومقترح امريكي همم دعوات قصد
لي الق في تنازلات والتفاوض ااه مع الجانب
التركي الانسحاب لمسافه 30 كيلو متر تسليم
بعض قيادات حزب العمال الكردستاني
المطلوبين من تركيا وايضا ان تنشئ تركيا
نقاط مشتركه او منفرده على الحدود يعني
اين الفرص اذا رفضت قصد هذه المقترحات هل
من فرص سياسيه اخرى
السياسيه موجوده هناك مشكله اساسيه اولا
ان الحكومه التركيه ترفض مفاضلات مباشره
مع قوات خاصه بشكل لا يقبل ابدا اختاره
طريق الحرب والقتال لا يفرقون بين قوات
خاصه وحزب العمال الكردستان عليها هذه ومن
جهه اخرى ان قوات خاصه لا يقبلون
المصالحه مع دمشق مثلا لو كانت هناك
بصراحه اتكلم لو كانت ترفع رايات سوريه في
مناطق كرديه في شماليه سوريا لكانت
المشكله منحله همم تنحل لكنه
القوات الاسد لا اتفاق ولا ياتي
تهدد فيها تركيا باقامه حزام امني
وبيعمليه بريه ما المختلف هذه المره رايك
لاننا نقترب من الانتخابات
كلما نقترب من الانتخابات في اي توتر
تركيا سوف تستفيد الحكومه الحاليه سوف
تستفيد من هذا التوتر لاعلان العمليه
العسكريه تجاه شمال سوريا او شمال العراق
نحن في السنين الماضي ايضا راينا انه كل
ما نقترب من الانتخابات قبيل الانتخابات
يدخلون في عمليه واسعه لان يجلبون اصوات
القوميين في داخل تركيا
من هذا الموضوع متعلق
بالقوات الكرديه في الشمال السوري بدون شك
هل باعتقادك العمليه الاخيره همم ستؤخر او
ستشدد الطلبات
تركيا على فنلندا والسويد في موضوع
العلاقه مع الاكراد
انا اظن انه الحكومه التركيه كسبت مكاسب
سياسيه في هذا الموضوع انه بلدان اعترف
بانه من الضروري ان مكافحه الارهاب داخل
فنان يا اسود هذا الامر يعني الحكومه
التركيه نحن نعرف في البدايه كانت هناك
تصريحات ناريه من قبل الحكومه التركيه لكن
مع مرور الزمن لان قدرات تركيا في داخل
حلف شمال الاطلس النت ايضا محدوده بشكل او
اخر ولهذا السبب سوف يصلون الى نتائج ولو
باغلاق بعض المكاتب همم قوات خاصه او حزب
العمال الكردستاني الارهابي في هذين
البلبلتين بشكل او اخر تركيا سوف تعلن عن
انتصارها السياسي في هذا الموضوع ولكن
ليست القضيه مرتبطه بالعمليه في شماليه
سوريا سوريا
شكرا
[موسيقى]
طلع مسؤول في الاتحاد الاوروبي ان زياره
رئيس المجلس الاوروبيين في الاول من
ديسمبر تهدف الى ترسيم الحدود بين الاتحاد
والباكين واضاف المسؤ
ول سينا
قشني علاقه بلاده مع رو
سيا الكبير على موس
كو كقارب خلال الفتره الماضيه بين دول
اوروبيه والصين
الصين تحدث طبعا داخل حلف شمال الاطلسي
بشان كيفيه التعامل الحلف مع بكين بحسب
صحيفه بوليتيكو الامريكيه اذا الدوريه
اشارت الى ان الخلافات حاده داخل الناتو
حياه الصين التي اعتبرها الحلف تحديا في
وقت سابقا من هذا العامه
لكن لم يتفقوا على كيفيه التعامل وطبيعه
العلاقات معها
اشار الى وجود تباينات داخل نيته بين
الصقور الذين لا يريدون اعداء بكين بشكل
مفرط والحمائم الذين يتحدثون عن الاعتماد
الاقتصاديه على الصين
الولايات المتحده يحاولون الموازنه بين
اهداف النيتو ورغبتهم في تقييد التكيين
وعلى الطرف الاخر دول مثل المجر التي تريد
التخفيف من اللهجه الحاده تجاه الصين
لدى النيته جوليان سميث قولها ان استراتي
الولايات المتحده والنيتو يمكن ان تكون
متوافقه الا انها اعترفت ان ترجمه اقوال
الحلف الى افعال قد تحتاجوا لوقت اطول
النقاش داخل النيتو مساله ما اذا كانت
الصين تستحق الكثير من الاهتمام في الوقت
الحالي في وقت تدور رح الحرب الاوكرانيه
في الفناء الخلفي
الدوريات الامريكيه اضافت ان القضيه ستكون
مطروحه على طاوله وزراء خارجيه دول النت
ويومي الثلاثاء والاربعاء في العاصمه
الرومانيه
بوخارستيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي ان اوروبا
لديها ما يكفي من التهديدات والتحديات في
السيناريو التقليدي للحلف واوضح انه لم
يتم وضع تصورا لعمليات النيته في المحيط
الهادئ لانه تحالف شمال الاطلسي واضاف ان
الاتحاد او على الاتحاد الاوروبي والنيتو
ان لا يخفى لا التحدي التحديات والتحديدات
الاخرى التي
التكتلناه
مجله فوري بوليسيه
لها ان المانيا تقود اهداف الوحده الغربيه
تجاه الصين
عندما وصلها في زياره خاطفه امتدت 11 ساعه
فقط في الرابعه من الشهر الجاري والسبق
شغل زيارته للصين بما قال في بوليتكو
اعتبر فيها انه حتى في ظل ظروف المتغيره
تظل الصين شريكا تجاريا مهما لالمانيا
واوروبا ولا يمكن الانفصال عنه
داخل الاحتلال الحاكم في المانيا عندما
اعترض وزير الخارجيه انا لينا بوك
والماليه روبرت هابيك وهما من حزب الخضر
على الاتفاقات المعقوده خلال اللقاء بين
برلين وقال الوزيران ان على المانيا
التوقف عن قبول ما وصفاه بالابتزاز
الصينيه
ترك بلقائه في بكين انطباعا قويا
لان اولوياته هي تعزيز العلاقات
الاقتصاديه لالمانيا مع الصين ما قد يضع
المانيا في موقع تكون فيه الحلقه الاضعف
في التحالف الغربي وقد تسعى الصين
لاستغلال ذلك المجله قالت انه بينما تحاول
دول الاوروبيه اتخاذا مقاربات موحده نحو
الصين حول الرئيس الصيني السجن التعامل مع
القاده الاوروبيين في مجموعه العشرين في
سوره منفرده مع تجنب اي لقاء رسمي مع
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ورئيس المجلس
الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 ايضا
رئيس المجلس الاوروبي في زياره الى الصين
لترسيم العلاقه بين بروكسل وفكين
[موسيقى]
يد الام ياما شاف الطول هالمشوار
ومع هذا لسه بتعرف كيف تختار حليب المراعي
الطازج الفرق بين الامهات
[موسيقى]
العسكريه هي احدى العوامل المحوريه
المؤثره
في قوه الدول
وحسن الزراعه
ولعل قاده العالم
يدركون مدى تاثيرها
[موسيقى]
فقد يعرفون اسرارا لا نعرفها
فمن يتحكم بموازين القوى وكيف تدار
الصفقات
الاكثر اهميه وتعقيدا وتنافسا في العالم
عسكريتاريا
السبت العاشره والنصف على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
من عده مصادر
من وسائل مختلفه طوال الوقت
[موسيقى]
ويستدعي ان نصلي الضوء عليه لمناقشه
نضعه في عدسه واحده
لنكبر الصوره لابعد القبول
[موسيقى]
على شاشه العربيه
اهلا بكم من جديد ده هجم الرئيس التنفيذي
لشركه وتر الى الماسك شركه ابل بعد وقفها
الاعلان في تويتر وطالبها بنشر اجراءات
الرقابه لحمايه عملائها وقال ماسك في
سلسله تغريدات على تويتر حددت بحجم تطبيق
تويتر من مجارها دون ابلاغهم بالاسباب
والفهمه ماسك ابل باتخاء او باخذ ضريبه
سريه بمقدار 30% من مطوري التطبيقات عبر
مجالها
نشر شركه ابل لاجراءات الرقابه لديها
ويمكن ان نتابع في هذا الاطار اضافه همم
الى همم يعني تغريده اخرى كتب فيها هل
ندفع يعني هل يجب ان يتم دفع 30% او
الذهاب الى الحرب ناشرا صوره لسياره تختار
بين الطريقين ب 120.000 همم اعجاب ونشاهد
ايضا همم التصويت
600 شخص حتى نعم
بصف الماسك حتى الان في هذا التصويت
قبل ان اتدقق في الموضوع لا افهم ما هو
تحديدا 86% فعلا نعم و14
لا ب 618000 يعني نحو 19,000 حتى الصوت
وصلت الى الان
ماسك يعني حافل باخذه للقرارات حسب
بالاعتماد على هذه
الفتره الاخيره صحيح
من ابرز الاتهامات التي واجهها الى
الماسكا بعد الاستحواذ على تويتر انه هو
سيسمح بظهور خطاب الكراهيه على المنصه لكن
هل تمتلك منصه تويتر القدره على مراقبه
ومحاسبه الحسابات المخالفه بعد اعلان
اعلان
[موسيقى]
الامان الخصوصيه الرسائل الخطره مفاتيح
اساسيه كانت محطه نقاش بعد استحواذ ايلون
ماسك على منصه تويتر قرارات متسارعه
للملياردير الاميركيه فتحت جدلا واسعا بين
الخبراء ومستخدميه تويتر لكن قراره الاخير
باصدار عفو عام عن الحسابات المجمده كان
الابرز موافقه اغلبيه مستخدم العصفور
الازرق على استفتاء ماسك حول فك حظر
الحسابات المجمده لا تعني موافقه الجميع
او انه قرار لا يتحمل عواقبه
خطط والهن ماسك قد تهدد بعوده خطابات
الكراهيه الى تويتر
حتى قبل تحركات اعاده الحسابات المحظوره
الا ان ذلك القرار انذار بعوده الدعوه
للعنف الا ان المالك الجديد لتويتر لديه
وجهه نظر اخرى لخصها بالارقام بحسب
احصاءات نشرها ماسك عن انجازات منصه منذ
استحواذه عليها فبات خطاب الكراهيه على
تويتر اقل بقرابه الثلث اعتبارا من الثالث
عشر من نوفمبر مقارنه بمنتصف اكتوبر من
العام الماضي اي انخفاض من 10 ملايين الى
مليون ونصف المليون
المتابعون لشؤون تويتر يرون ان السياسات
الارتجاريه التي اتخذها ماسك في المنصه
ستعود عليه بالسلب خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالتحكم في حريه التعبير والمعايير
المنظمه له فكيف لتويتر ان تطبق قواعد
المحتوى في وقت يعفو فيه مصر عن حسابات
المحظوره لاسباب بعضها يتعلق بخطابات
الكراهيه والعنف من جهه ومن جهه اخرى موجه
من الطرد والاستقالات ادت لتقليس عدد
الموظفين بشكل كبير جزء منهم وظيفته
الاساسيه مراقبه واتخاذ اجراءات ضد
الحسابات المخالفه للقواعد
صوره اليوم من العربيه 360 من مباراه
كوريا الجنوبيه وغانا في كاس العالم اليوم
في استاد المدينه التعليميه الشعار الذي
يتوسط على ما بلادهم بصوره نجم منتخبهم
سون هيونغ مين لكن اداء اليوم لم يكن
كافيا الفوز من غانا النجمه
وتصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 لنائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي دمت ريمدف الذي تحدث عن
سيناريوهات قائمه لمستقبل علاقات
الامريكيه الاوروبيه يقول بان الزواج بين
الولايات المتحده واوروبا مهدد بالانتهاء
بفضيحه قادره بسبب الخيانه الامريكيه
المصالح اوروبا
الشركات الاوروبيه في اقتصادها دون ان
تهتم بتاثير ذلك على السوق الاوروبيه
فيديو اليوم من العاصمه البلجيكيه بركسال
لاحتجاجات لضباط الشرطه هناك
ضباط الشرطه
والاساءات التي توجه اليهم في التظاهره
قسم الضباط يطهر الى ثلاثه فئات الالاف من
المتظاهرين وهم من الضباط غير المداومين
اليوم وعدد قليل من المتظاهرين قرر ان
يقوم بدور الامن في التظاهره وذلك لضبتها
اما الحكم الاخر الثالث